hi I'm Ryan the right I am gonna be
watching the Super Bowl trailers part 1
and part 2 of the amazing spider-man
part DOS I'm excited to watch this
because I [ __ ] love the amazing
spider-man I thought it was great you
know I was totally against the reboot
but then when that one came out I saw it
I was [ __ ] blown away man
blown away
alright so this is part one this is the
first one first one you ready guys ready
- ready let's do this yes spider-man so
cool
: sands warm rainy Peter
we got Captain America coming out they
got [ __ ] x-men Days of Future past
coming out for some reason those 30
seconds hook me the most you know I love
the x-men movies but damn that oh this
looks so good I can't wait to watch part
two now we're not the wait till sea rule
Sunday we can just watch it together
right now right here we go 30 more
seconds of Awesomeness I'm sure of it
ring kabhi face I was clean it was
pretty funny
I like that jaws joke Spidey and his
sense of humor gosh
nothing like a good comic book hero with
a sense of humor